[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette édition
spéciale à vos masques c'est la rentrée
une rentrée exceptionnelle en raison de
la pandémie à cette occasion france 3 a
quitté les studios pour retrouver les
salles de classe nous sommes à belfort
au lycée raoul follereau
ici comme partout ailleurs ce matin la
cloche a bien sonné pour les 250 mille
élèves de l'académie de besançon
des élèves qui à partir de 11 ans
doivent être masqué doivent respecter
également de nombreuses consignes
sanitaires
écoutez ce qu'en pensent les principaux
intéressés parce que c'est vrai que ce
qu'ils ont en face est particulière déjà
par le port du masque pour tout le monde
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un peu
bizarre ça va on attendait mais déjà là
notre disposition puis on a des masques
puis on est séparés dans les classes
donc ses principales je trouve que c'est
bien qu'est-ce qu'ils ont mis pour
l'instant soir mais ça va vite devenir
insupportable je pense j'ai pas trop
stressé à redire je me sens plutôt à
l'aise le chef d'orchestre de cette
rentrée ici au lycée raoul follereau de
belfort c'est le proviseur dominique
ballon bonsoir bonsoir on a entendu des
jeunes qui disait bon bah c'est vraiment
le supportent d'autres on va pas le
supporter longtemps le masque c'est
vraiment l'objet particulier de cette
rentrée très spécial c'est vraiment ce
qu'il est indispensable de porter tel
que le prévoient les le protocole
sanitaire
alors on sait bien que c'est pas
agréable mais c'est une obligation pour
protéger les autres comment vous avez
senti les élèves ce matin est ce que
pour eux ça y est c'est ea qui s'était
accepté oui j'ai remarqué que c'était
assez naturel nous avions des élèves en
soutien scolaire la semaine passée j'en
ai pas vu un seul sans masque ce matin
on leur a demandé de mettre un masque
dès qu'ils franchissaient la grille mais
ça c'est plutôt bien fait alors je ne
vous dis pas que à certains moments de
la journée s'est passé c'est pas pénible
mais voilà c'est cette chose et c'est
une rentrée qui est un petit peu étalé
ans et ça pour justement que toulouse
rennes bien connaissance des règles
absolument nous avons
nous faisons une rentrée progressive
aujourd'hui nous avions les élèves de
seconde générale et technologique et pro
les élèves de cp
les élèves de 3e prépa métier voilà les
nouveaux effectivement il ya de très
nombreux élèves puisque il faut le dire
ici on peut avoir jusqu'à 2000 personnes
sur ce et bien on devrait pas se parler
d'un campus tellement ce lycée est vaste
il y à 16 bâtiments autour de nous et
puis et bien ça s'est réveillée la
semaine dernière sous le regard
d'anthony halpern et maxim haut niveau
le lycée raoul follereau
c'est ça une immense cité scolaire de 10
hectares comprenant 16 bâtiments jusqu'à
1850 élèves sont attendus à la rentrée
presque une ville dans la ville ici à
belfort qui somnole encore à quelques
jours de la reprise des cours tout juste
certains agents s'activent dans la plus
grande discrétion
chaque jour des milliers de mètres
carrés de surface passe tous ept
serpillière ou le matin c'est des
infections des salles qui sont occupés
avec les vacances apprenantes douter les
tables des élèves les bureaux des profs
les infections des sols des toilettes
des couloirs des escaliers des rampes et
poignets à tout ça à l'extérieur c'est
raphaël aux commandes
à bord de son tracteur il tond la
pelouse avant de tailler les haies le
jardinier doit remettre en état 2 à 3
hectares de terrain après plus d'un mois
de vacances je fais à peu près cette
surface qui a derrière moi tous les
jours et puis des fois même plus parce
que bon j'ai quand même à triel asei
récent et je suis très bien équipée donc
j'arrive à faire face quand même dans
les cuisines on s'active aussi avec une
difficulté supplémentaire cette année le
réaménagement du réfectoire pour
respecter la distanciation sociale la
capacité de la cantine habituellement de
3 180 couverts est réduite à 150
d'habitude nous travaillons pour 850
courir 2010 là on ne sait pas combien on
va venir dont on compare carrément ce
que l'inconnu mais on s est géré au
mieux le chef d'orchestre c'est lui
philippe bardet doite organisé chaque
été la remise en marche de cette énorme
machine
pour ce qui est du courant et du
quotidien on est huilé mais comme chaque
année on d'année des nouveautés il est
bien évident qu'on doit s'adapter en
fonction des nouvelles implantations qui
ont être mise en place
au total 70 agences à faire depuis le 20
août pour offrir la meilleure entrée
possible aux élèves
alors dominique ballon est ce que la
taille de l'établissement est un
problème dans la gestion justement 2d
les pieds des risques d'épidémies n'ont
pas véritablement on a l'habitude de
fonctionner il ya effectivement deux
établissements en un vous l'avez rappelé
il ya 16 bâtiments il ya de quoi
accueillir tout le monde
il ya des choses qu'on peut pas faire
j'imagine par contre qui reste même si
l'espace est très très vaste qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on ne peut plus faire
aujourd'hui au lycée dès lors que l'on
est protégé et que l'on respecte les
gestes barrière la distanciation
physique etc on est attentif à à limiter
autant que faire se peut le brassage
entre individus je ne vois pas
énormément de choses qui soient
interdits un sport par exemple il ya un
nouveau il y a une fiche technique qui
est sorti ce week-end samedi matin qui
dit qu'on peut pratiquer l'activité
physique en restant à au moins deux
mètres de distance entre les élèves non
masqué mais cela veut dire
qu'effectivement on peut pas pratiquer
vas-y des jeux collectifs pas de judo
mais il ya moyen de faire du step ya
moyen de faire des activités
ça c'est important parce que les élèves
avaient envie de reprendre bien sûr que
vous avez senti ça qu'il y avait
vraiment une ambiance presque comme
avant
bien sûr il avait envie de reprendre on
peut pratiquer de l' escalade dès lors
qu'on les seules conditions après de
désinfecter les points sur lesquels
l'élève s'est appuyé l'essentiel c'est
ce que vous disiez c'est d'éviter le
bras là et puis les activités quand même
en plein air à l'extérieur on peut donc
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire alors
on va aller dans un site stratégique
c'est l'un des rares sites où on peut
enlever son masque la cantine on y
retrouve tout de suite maxime haut
niveau maxime monfort comment est-ce que
ça s'organise du côté de la restauration
scolaire
on a dû réorganiser pas mal de choses ce
bar à salade
il a été totalement recouverte de papier
c
idem avec sept fontaines à eau qui
d'habitude un cerf pour remplir les
braults qui sont utilisés par les
lycéens ici tout a été emballé
soigneusement pour éviter tout risque de
contamination éviter des contacts manuel
entre les différents lycées 1
regardez également sur les tables les
distances de sécurité sont respectées
les élèves sont installés en quinconce
pour éviter qu'ils ne se trouvent face à
face l'un avec l'autre
là encore le but c'est d'éviter toute
contamination
et puis regardez du coup la conséquence
c'est que chaque élève doit se saisir de
ces bouteilles d'eau morse le pain et
les couverts le là aussi le but c'est
d'éviter tout contact entre le personnel
des cuisines et puis les lycéens merci
maximale et on pose les plateaux
puisqu'il va bientôt être 19 heures on
va faire un point sur l'actualité
[Musique]
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez sur
france 3 franche comté nous avons quitté
nos studios pour retrouver les salles de
classe pour parler de cette rentrée
scolaire une rentrée exceptionnelle en
raison bien sûr de la pandémie mais tout
de suite on fait un point sur
l'actualité dans l'actualité aujourd'hui
à compter de ce 1er septembre
eh bien il est désormais obligatoire de
se promener dans le centre ville de
besançon avec un masque la boucle masqué
c'est un reportage de laurent du creuset
jean stéphane moris il y avait comme du
changement ce matin dans ce que l'on
appelle la boucle tous les marcheurs ou
presque avancer masqué on vient de
découvrir là en voyant un panneau un
petit peu plus loin donc on découvre un
peu au fur et à mesure ses pancartes
viennent en effet d'être installés un
peu partout dans la zone concernée
une décision qui semble ne pas
surprendre au grand mot je comprends
tout à fait parce que je tiens
obligatoire parts dans sa terrible
eh ben ça sert à protéger les gens donc
je comprends tout à faire l'obligation
de l'emporter et nous pouvons le porte
depuis ce matin oui enfin que l'ailier
anglais vu en tout cas les portais ce
n'est pas 800 on entend parler de cette
mesure là dans toutes les villes presque
une après l'autre alors ça m'a pas pas
surpris
ça fait longtemps que de moi même je
porte le masque parce que quand je sors
je vais toujours dans un magasin pas de
chance pour les jo d'heures qu'ils
doivent continuer à porter un masque
les cyclistes en revanche ne sont pas
concernées par cette obligation
j'ai demandé aux policiers municipaux ce
matin si c'était autorisé il
assuré que voilà on avait le droit de
faire du vélo sans masque on pourra
toujours mangé un sandwich et fumer une
cigarette dans la rue mais de manière
statique et en respectant la
distanciation physique la menthe pour le
non port du masque s'élève à 135 euros
et masqués ou non vous pouvez appuyer un
peu plus sur la d'accélération à
compter d'aujourd'hui sur certaines
routes du jura 300 km qui repasse à 90
pour le président du département c'était
une attente forte des habitants qui se
déplacent principalement en voiture on a
jugé quand même que cette mesure du 80
km et est particulièrement contraignante
pour pour les territoires ruraux au
territoire la voiture le moyen de
mobilité est essentielle
donc il était clair que noël contraintes
de limitations de vitesse étaient guère
supportable par des administrés
d'ailleurs beaucoup se sont plaints de
cette mesure gouvernementale retour à
belfort nous sommes en direct du lycée
raoul follereau pour parler de la
rentrée scolaire une rente est
exceptionnelle et qui a bien eu lieu
pour 250 mille élèves en franche-comté
des élèves pour la plupart masqués à
partir de 11 ans nous sommes avec le
proviseur de cet établissement
bonsoir dominique bahl ombreux bonsoir
bonsoir le masque c'est une évidence
effectivement maintenant tout le monde
le port est ce qu'il ya des moments
quand même on pense que vous êtes un
lycée professionnel donc il ya des
parties techniques
est ce qu'il ya des moments où les
élèves peuvent quand même l'enlever si
vraiment par exemple ils font des
activités trop physique que tu vois bien
que c'est trop physique oui on a parlé
tout à l'heure du gymnase c'est tout à
fait autorisé en revanche autant que
faire se peut il faut le garder que
lorsqu'on est en atelier si ça ne cause
pas de problème parce que sinon voilà on
commence à déroger à la règle et ça peut
pas aller il y avait une crainte du côté
des enseignants aussi peut-être par
rapport aux rapports qu'on peut avoir
avec les élèves quand on est masquée oui
bien sûr on peut le comprendre c'est pas
évident d'enseigner avec un masque je
pense aux professeurs de langues
vivantes par exemple qui doivent à un
moment donné montrer avec leurs lèvres
le mot à prononcer s'est passé pas
simple et je me mets à leur place mais
on n'a pas lu le texte dit que dans les
lieux clos où l'on doit porter un masque
prononce voici en dessous des conditions
nécessaires pour les autres si jamais il
y avait un cas où plusieurs cas de
corona virus dans l'établissement
qu'elle est le protocole à suivre
ak serait déjà bien je ne souhaite pas
plusieurs mais un protocole existe dans
un établissement comme le nôtre
le proviseur a à sa disposition deux
infirmières donc on a on a du personnel
de santé de les isoler l'élève est isolé
dans une salle dédiée
il ya un risque de fermeture
d'établissement on verra on verra pour
le trajet en toutes lettres visage
puisqu'il ya un plan de continuité
pédagogique qui existent au cas où
voilà on en n'est pas là pour le moment
et c'est l'essai toute façon pas le
proviseur qui décidera rapidement sur
les conséquences peut-être avec les
entreprises qui elles aussi d'un travail
avec justement vous avez pas mal de
lycéens et d'apprentis
l'aïe a des conséquences oui je ne vous
cache pas qu'on a quelques inquiétudes
surtout pour les élèves qui doivent
partir en entreprise à la fin du mois
des élèves de terminale qui avait une
convention signée au mois de juin et qui
vient d'être annulé par l'entreprise
parce que l'entreprise dit qu'elle n'est
pas en mesure d'accueillir dans des
conditions convenables
l'élève qu'elle avait prévu d'accueillir
donc on y travaille on va accompagner
ses élèves mais c'est pas c'est pas très
simple pour les autres stages dans
l'année
à mon avis on rencontrera moins de
difficulté vous allez essayer en tout
cas de vous adapter fur et à mesure
merci beaucoup
on va aller voir maxime maxime qui est
bien avec des élèves qui sont en
internat puisque le lycée est bien un
internat oui aude nous sommes
actuellement dans une chambre vous le
voyez pour parler de cet internat avec
mélusine bonjour mélusine alors tu es
élèves de seconde et toi c'est ta
première année ici à l'internât qu'est
ce que tu en penses pour l'instant tu as
découvert
carthage en effet beaucoup c'est simple
c'est une forme d'indépendance ceci donc
ça change de la maison et j'ai fait
beaucoup de bonnes rencontres
globalement qu'est ce qui t'a fait
choisir l'internât plutôt que de rester
chez tes parents le soir principalement
pour des raisons géographiques et aussi
pour tenter une nouvelle expérience
parce que ça aurait été compliqué de
venir et de retourner tous les soirs tu
habites où ça les alentours des d'accord
donc ça a été compliqué oui ça fait un
petit bout
ok et puis il ya aussi la ferveur enfin
le fait d'être ensemble c'est important
aussi entre entraîneurs vous soutenez ça
c'est convivial tout le monde est gentil
agréable on se fait des petits sourires
dans les couloirs tout ça bon pour
l'instant on va dire que la rentrée se
passe bien alors et donc il ya mélusine
qui découvrait l'internât et puis on va
aller voir une autre étudiante cé awa
bonsoir alors à wael elle est en
étudiant en deuxième année de prépa
maths sup pea si tu as toi décidé de
revenir à l'internât tu étais déjà là
l'an dernier pourquoi ce choix de
revenir en fait je pense que l'internât
c'est vraiment le meilleur endroit pour
apprendre parce qu'on a une bonne
ambiance de travail
on s'entraide en plus y'a pas la
concurrence
on vit comme on était enfin me croire
mais plus foncé j'ai toujours avancé le
maire n'aura quoi c'est tout et il ya du
soutien mutuel entre étudiants de
différentes années et également oui
franchement parfois l'année dernière
quand j'étais un premier rennais pour
faire quand j'étais bloqué dans mes
exams j'allais aux élèves sur les élèves
de deuxième année qui me soutenaient
franchement voilà donc de la solidarité
entre les différentes étudiants ici à
l'internât de la solidarité
effectivement entre les étudiants aussi
avec les professeurs deux m'ont rejoint
à marie-france à gaillard et linda
l'hypothèque merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes professeur ici donc dans les
filières classiques mais aussi dans les
filières professionnelles
est ce que vous êtes heureuse de
retrouver enfin j'allais dire tous vos
élèves
mais oui forcément un forcément surtout
après près tout ce temps tout à fait
vous avez vécu une période très
particulière le confinement ça a été
très particulier néanmoins est ce qu'il
ya des choses positives qui ressortent
de cette expérience et que vous allez
j'avais dire utiliser pour cette rentrée
linda l'ipo vagues peut-être vous vous
travaillé notamment avec les laisser
happer oui principalement sur les crp
donc en filière filières
professionnelles donc effectivement le
confinement ça a été très particulier ça
a été une période qui a été une période
de travail très laborieuse mieux au
final avec le recul qui s'est plutôt
bien passé
tous vos élèves d'ailleurs on hull s'est
à peine examen accroché on parle souvent
des décrocheurs mais du coup tous les
élèves ont leur ca fait à l'exception
d'une mais indépendamment du confinement
et puis on a réussi à maintenir le lien
justement le lien dans les
apprentissages mais également le lien
social avec les élèves tous à bruxelles
et continuer à garder des groupes comme
ça les groupes de travail des groupes
d'entre elles entre les élèves
oui tout à fait on va poursuivre on va
poursuivre également le travail via la
plateforme numérique et klein 1 cave est
à notre disposition l'année dernière
mais qui le sera toujours
donc c'est un outil indispensable aussi
qu'on va mettre en place et faire
utiliser les élèves dès la rentrée
scolaire
et puis on va continuer à créer ce lien
justement avec les élèves on s'est rendu
compte que pour canal et puis seront
rentrés dans les apprentissages c'est
indispensable que l'enseignant lui fasse
confiance mais aussi que cette confiance
soit réciproque
vous êtes d'accord marie france pour ça
a beaucoup parlé des élèves décrocheurs
non on peut dire que pendant confinement
on a eu aussi des élèves raccrocheurs
c'est à dire des élèves dont on pensait
les avoir perdus et qui sont revenus se
connecter et qui ont suivi les cours et
c'était bien et on sait qu'il ya des
élèves effectivement motivé on va
s'interrompre à quelques instants
puisque je voudrais justement vous
montrer un reportage qui étaient tournés
du côté de limoges dans un lycée
professionnel où dès la semaine dernière
pendant leurs vacances et bien des
élèves motivés effectivement sont
retournés un peu plus tôt sur les bancs
de l'école regardez vous allez me
programmer une commande général qui
commande simultanément les deux volets
roulants d'accord nous sommes au beau
milieu des vacances d'été pourtant ces
lycéens sont en pleins travaux pratiques
élève en bac professionnel métiers de
l'électricité
ils viennent se perfectionner à quatre
semaines de la rentrée
car si les cours ont continué à distance
tout n'a pas pu être approfondie pendant
le confinement en a pas mal d'élèves qui
ont répondu présent donc ça permet
effectivement de de voir des choses
qu'on n'a pas pu faire on a fait bien
sûr des courants distant ciel mais
malheureusement les cours dates phares
et les travaux pratiques en distance
yale c'est quand même très difficile
donc là ça nous permet vraiment de feu
de rattraper finalement ce qu'ils n'ont
pas pu voir alors pourquoi qui
s'inquiètent parce que les élèves qui
sont pas venus on veut leur verra
l'année prochaine les vacances
apprenantes permet aussi d'avoir un
avant-goût
de l'année scolaire à venir l'atelier
soudure de fibre optique a par exemple
beaucoup intéressé ces futurs lycéens ça
bien ça me prépare l'année prochaine
maintenant tu vas démonter le bloc des
caméras et nous parle heures les cours
sont informelles
les adolescents ont choisi leur matière
l'ambiance est donc studieuse mais
détendue
les jeunes ont l'impression de ne pas
être dans le même cadre d'enseignement
cas de plus jour plus rigide avec des
impératifs la petite qui sont
l'impression d'être dans quelque chose
de plus de pluie froid alors que
finalement dans le fond l'activité la
façon d'amener est quasiment la même
quoi
qui dit vacances apprenantes dit tout de
même vacances certaines activités sont
donc bien plus ludiques comme cette
initiation au théâtre
les vacances sont bel et bien terminées
on se remet au travail un travail qui va
falloir suivre de près j'imagine pour
éviter qu'ils aient des écarts qui se
creusent
vous avez des moyens justement d'éviter
qu'ils aider les gens qui décroche oui à
la rentrée pour les secondes ça c'est
prévu comme d'habitude il ya les les
tests de positionnement qui sont prévues
pour les seconds
mais on aura aussi les moyens d'avoir
des heures pour éventuellement prendre
les élèves qui auront des difficultés
donc on aura des moyens pour les
arrondis c'est quoi pour vous c'est un
confinement
oui oui vraiment oui oui c'est vrai que
ça reste une crème mais ça reste une
crainte aussi pour les élèves en ont
parlé
encore ce matin pour laquelle on n'a pas
la réponse mais l'appareil a tenté de
les rassurer que sir confinement il y
avait vous savez qu'on est là des
solutions
est ce qu'il ya des choses quand même
qu'il faudrait améliorer on a beaucoup
parlé du numérique
oui notamment peut-être aussi de
l'utilisation qu'en font les professeurs
est ce que ça c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut le nombre d'outils on a beaucoup
d'outils donc peut-être hui se recentrer
sur des outils les plus utilisés pour
que tout le monde utilise les mêmes les
mêmes chemins même sur quoi vous parlez
d'entre aide effectivement entre vous et
semi il ya de l'entr'aide maintenu entre
professeurs peut-être plus qu'avant pas
oui oui 3 dans le confinement oui on
peut sentir quand même qu'il ya une
grande entraide entre les enseignants à
certains étaient plus aguerris on y va
d'un niveau informatique
c'est entre edel s'est développé autant
chez les enseignants et au fur et à
mesure du confinement elle s'est
développée aussi chez les élèves à
envoyer des élèves qui cédaient entre
eux sans même que professeurs
interviennent
merci beaucoup mesdames d'avoir été
invité sur ce plateau va continuer bien
sûr à parler des élèves qui pour
certains est bien dans quelques jours à
peine vont passer le bac le rattrapage
du bac il ya aussi des rattrapages de
bts le bac on le sait qui a été réformé
cette réforme qui a soulevé beaucoup de
questions beaucoup de manifestations il
ne s'est pas une première dans
l'histoire de france regardez ce rappel
de maxime de nouveau depuis sa création
en 1808 le bac n'a cessé de se réforme
dans les années 1950 il reste très
exigeant et ne concerne que 5 % d'une
classe d'âge
une proportion qui ne cessera
d'augmenter en 1968 les filières abcde
sont instaurés ainsi qu'un bac
technologique
en 1985 le belfortain jean pierre
chevènement alors ministre de
l'éducation nationale créé le bac
professionnel et fixe un objectif
ambitieux ce baccalauréat professionnel
nous permettra d'avoir je l'espère nous
y travaillons 80 % d'une classe d'âge en
l'an 2000 qui ira jusqu'au niveau du
baccalauréat c'est à dire deux fois plus
qu'aujourd'hui
en 1993 les trois grandes séries du bac
général
l es et s sont créés françois bayrou
alors en charge de la réforme
il ya sur la possibilité de choisir des
options pour favoriser l'apprentissage
des langues anciennes
en 2005 une grande réforme du bac est
envisagée par françois fillon
le projet est de ne garder que six
matière est de faire évaluer les autres
par contrôle continu mais il provoque
une forte opposition des lycéens comme
ici à besançon on s'est renseignés ont
été influencés par personne
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire
aucun professeur nous a influencés on a
fait l'autre choses tout seul tout seul
on est venu depuis morteau on s'est
débrouillé pour unir depuis morteau et
personne n'est venu derrière nous donc
ça je pense que c'est vraiment important
le projet sera finalement abandonné tout
comme celui imaginé trois ans plus tard
par xavier darcos
enfin dernière réforme en date celles
mises en oeuvre par jean michel blanquer
air à partir de 2010
désormais les trois filières du bac
général sont abandonnés à la place des
disciplines comme une obligatoire et des
disciplines de spécialités au choix des
élèves
le contrôle continu est aussi introduit
et comptent désormais pour 40% de la
note finale
un grand oral de 20 minutes est
également instauré une petite révolution
dans un examen qui n'a cessé d'évoluer
et la réforme du bac est bien à elle est
bien sûr toujours en cours malgré
l'épidémie elle a été à l'épreuve du
confinement avec nous deux invités jean
françois chanet
recteur de l'académie de besançon dance
for choix est à vos côtés un professeur
militant fsu benoît cuir merci d'être
avec nous bonsoir
est ce que le confinement ce que l'année
dernière ça a perturbé justement la mise
en place de cette réforme et ça
peut-être encore plus perturbée les
élèves qui est bien on était j'allais
dire était aux premières loges
ça les a fait douter peut-être de la
valeur de l'examen qu'il faut combattre
car dans notre académie les épreuves
communes de contrôle continu ont eu lieu
et se sont bien passées et le travail
qui a été fait pendant le confinement
permet de garantir que l'obtention du
baccalauréat ne valait pas moins cette
année que les années précédentes de
noyon à ce qu'est une crainte d'avoir un
bac au rabais justement j'aimerais dire
deux mois déjà que nous avons bien sûr
plaisir à retrouver les élèves en cette
rentrée après après des mois finalement
sans sans classe et nous sommes bien
conscients justement des difficultés qui
vont se présenter à nous et bien sûr le
confinement a donc sans doute créer plus
made in égalité bien sûr que le lien
s'est distendu vont sans doute avec les
élèves
mais le lien avec l'école mais il y a il
est des choses très simples pour tenir
compte de l'année qui vient de s'écouler
pour faire en sorte que les élèves
réussissent position on est pressé par
le temps même où nous les avons fait ces
provisions dès le mois de mai c'est à
dire reporter ces épreuves de contrôle
continu à la fin de l'année limiter ses
nouveaux programmes puisque là
clairement rien n'est fait par le
ministère pour me tenir compte
est-ce que rien n'est fait pour les
élèves c'est non
ce n'est pas ce que pense mon jeune
collègue il faut pas ya des choses en
place très rapide et bien sûr que
certaines des propositions des
organisations syndicales ont été retenus
la preuve c'est que les épreuves de
contrôle continu ont été modifiés est ce
que le regretter mais une rentrée une
rentrée c'est un miroir dans lequel se
regarde la nation je suis désolé je vous
demander d'être très concret ce cas par
exemple des heures qui sont prévues pour
les élèves pour attraper les éclairs il
est prévu surtout de donner une vraie
valeur à l'accompagnement personnalisé
ce n'est pas ce ne sont pas de vains
mots accompagnement personnalisé ça
longtemps servi à rattraper les contenus
des programmes
la question des programmes nous savons
que cette question des programmes et
sempiternel mans posée l'important ce
n'est pas les programmes c'est ce que
les élèves apprennent ces sauvages on va
peut-être justement retient on va
retrouver maxime maxime qui est dans le
foyer de l'internât qui est justement
avec un jeune étudiant de savoir s'il ya
des craintes justement sur l'avenir oui
au d'effectivement nous sommes dans le
foyer regardez ici à l'intérieur on a
tout prévu il ya même un baby foot pour
permettre aux lycéens de se relaxer et
c'est important notamment pour les
étudiants en prépa en classe prépa c'est
le cas de susan bonsoir suzanne alors
vous êtes étudiante en deuxième année de
prépa maths sup
expliquez-nous c'est toujours un peu
stressant la rentrée pour le moment ça
va mais après on va voir les concours
qui vont arriver très vite donc plus les
échéances à harry est plus stressant est
ce que l'on voit vous avez le masque est
ce que le coc vide rajoute un petit peu
de difficultés dans la classe prépa
qu'est déjà des fois un parcours du
combattant pour les lycéens françois pas
tant que ça c'est juste qu'on a le port
du masque obligatoire en classe est con
et distanciée donc on a pas on est un
portable mais autrement non c'est pas si
problématique que ça et on préfère être
en cours présentiels que à distance
merci beaucoup suzanne et puis voyez si
jamais les et lycéens et les étudiants
veulent se détendre et aussi un billard
ici dans le foyer de l'internât
ben si maxime qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter pour cette rentrée qu'est-ce
qu'il faut absolument qu'elle est la
priorité pour vous monsieur chalet
garder ce calme cette sérénité cette
confiance en nous mêmes parce que c'est
ça qui rassure les familles on parle de
les rassurer mais rien ne les rassure un
plus que c'est tranquille assurance que
nous avons deux c'est à dire même si par
exemple il doit y avoir un confinement
c'est pas grave on sait faire mon entrée
pour vous monsieur guillon que le
ministère sorte de son déni de réalité
et qu'ils le prennent exemple sur nos
voisins l'espagne l'italie qui ont
recruté du personnel supplémentaire pour
faire des groupes réduits et pour
permettre de faire progresser les élèves
les plus fragiles donc faire prendre des
mesures pour aider les élèves notamment
les plus en difficulté merci beaucoup à
tous les deux on vous souhaite une belle
rentrée on va souhaiter aussi une belle
rentrée bien sûr au proviseur du lycée
raoul follereau qui nous a accueilli
aujourd'hui à belfort
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter à
vous aussi pour cette rentrée et à tous
vos élèves
bon écoute et que tout allait pour le
mieux possible que nous n'ayons pas à
vivre une situation plus critique pour
le moment comme le dit monsieur le
recteur il faut être serein cette
rentrée pour moi est marqué du sceau de
la remobilisation scolaire il faut
absolument que les élèves puissent
retrouver le chemin de l'école après
tant de semaines en confinement et même
après au moment du décompte final ne
sont certains ne sont pas revenus donc
il s'agit vous allez suivre un peu plus
bien sûr mais c'est le discours que j'ai
tenu aux enseignants on a on va
accompagner encore de manière plus qu'on
ne le fait les élèves de manière
personnalisée
voilà et puis on va surtout faire un
bilan
on va pas rentrer dans les programmes
tout de suite on va on va priver on
pourrait dire ça comme ça on va prendre
le temps de prendre le temps pour
évaluer remédier consolidé avant
d'entrer dans les apprentissages
merci beaucoup dominique ballon
proviseur du lycée elle qui nous a
accueillis on va se quitter sur ces
images de cette rentrée si particulière
cette rentrée scolaire 2020 et merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi le prochain
rendez vous avec l'info c'est à 11h52 ma
belle soirée
[Musique]
ce qui est intéressant dans